we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
um this is a voicemail from troy york we
haven't heard from him for a while he
calls in with my podcast playing in the
background and that's indeed what
happened here
he is uh unleashing a very serious
criticism against me because i once ate
food when i was in san diego california
listen to this
um uh david peckman
he's talking about the special
when i heard your recent broadcast you
took a phone call
from a guy from san diego
and you said you were in san diego
and you loved all the restaurants
when you said that this pretty much
demonstrates
what i always thought
you are a elitist
and your income is way too high and this
is fight
why you speak all the talking points you
did yeah
you know um i think troy is right when i
was in san diego i shouldn't have eaten
food or i should i should have just
stayed in my hotel room eating crackers
that's what i should have done the fact
that i went to a restaurant and liked it
clearly shows
that i am an out of touch elitist i i
did i i did consume food
uh and that was a biological need i will
mention these folks are really really
strange we have a fantastic bonus show
for you today joe biden has announced
the first
pardons of his presidency
75 commutations and three pardons will
be granted to people charged with
low-level drug offenses or non-violent
crimes
this is presumably just the beginning
we're going to talk about these 78
pardons and commutations on today's
bonus show we have now learned that the
pandemic has erased a decade of public
preschool gains
we had seen over the 10 years leading up
to the pandemic
increased funding and enrollment in
state-based preschool programs now we
can argue what's the best type of
preschool program and that has the best
outcomes sure that's a debate we can
have but we had worked to fund and
enroll kids in preschool
that gain has been completely undone by
the pandemic and it has not resumed so
far
depressing depressing and lastly we're
going to take a deeper dive at elon
musk's
claim that he wants to bring real free
speech to twitter
his track record on speech is a little
shaky when it comes to unions and when
it comes to different things so we're
going to be looking into that and
evaluating what is likely to happen on
twitter we talked at the top of the show
about
the losses of followers among many
left-wing accounts and the gains of
followers among many right-wing accounts
we're gonna dive more deeply into the
free speech elements of this all of
those stories are on today's bonus show
i would love for you to sign up for the
bonus show it's easy you go to
joinpakman.com
you just sign up you can pay monthly you
can pay yearly you can use the coupon
code wow 22 to get a discount and very
importantly if you already have a
membership and you want to do a little
more we now have a running list of
people who want a free membership people
who want a membership but can't afford
one there are currently 700 people
waiting
700 people
waiting
for a membership they're just sitting
around waiting
you can fulfill one of their dreams or
many
by checking that this is a gift box when
you go through the sign up process on
our website it's the normal process but
there's a box that asks is this a gift
you check it
and then
the next person in line of the 700 will
get a free membership which is a
beautiful thing i will see you on the
bonus show otherwise we'll be back
tomorrow